hello there reject nation of Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the Star Wars rise of Skywalker special
featurette today but before we do that
we got ourselves a sponsor Husting jerk
um finally got our first official
website off the ground more of a
homepage the real rejects dot-com and
since our last shout out where I admit
it I don't properly know how to
pronounce their name they still have
included up for me its hosting or com
doesn't know what I said the page is
still a work in progress but that's not
a problem because hosting are made it
incredibly easy to register our domain
and start building our site through
WordPress that's right people John did
all the work and I resent him yeah
hosting gurjar offers a variety of web
hosting and design options along with
enhance security 24-hour customer
support and an incredible ease-of-use
look into livestream your Jedi fallen
order let's plays huh good call name in
that game because it's Star Wars host
singer has Virtual Private servers to
get you started looking to share your
handmade baby Yoda bellybutton rings
with the world huh singer can help you
set up a store even if all you need is
an outlet for your steamy Po and thin
fan fiction hosting ur has a fast secure
option for you whoa
fit in Pope who are they head on over to
hosting er comm slash the real rejects -
check him out and save 91 percent on an
annual web hosting plan when you use our
code the real rejects that is like a cup
that is eight percent away from being
full nine what are you ready for people
doing
oh boy Nebraska and not on top so cool
nerds in behind the scenes
[Music]
we're sort of finished but hopefully it
will justify it as a series make you say
gee what happens next
the whole experience has been Oh Carly
Wow unanticipated I haven't my doubts
about whether another Star Wars would
work but I now get that phrase thank you
that my childhood because it's something
that people carry with them now forever
than ever moment
oh nice as I have see hmm this is
nothing to do with past present or
future Star Wars could be in any of
those areas it's a big part of what
makes these films so important to pass
on from generation to generation on it
I've been allowed to continue the
journey it's very cool to meet someone
inspirational to a generation of Florida
goers
those that have gone before you
incredible artists in their own right
you don't deepen your appreciation and
respect that oh my gosh it feels like it
was just in a time machine and I had
traveled back to when they first started
filming Star Wars
if you're a kid watching this a hundred
years from now five hundred years from
now
you see this inevitability the story
conclude in a way that feels thrilling
and shocking and funny and emotional and
satisfying
I like these bones I think there's a
legacy that's important
be a conclusion of a story that is over
40 years of thinking
so all stops are out and it's all go
rise of the horizon the nips
all right let's watch this friendship
feature Aetna has a great history to
read only that original cast was no
right though there'll be a featurette
like this in like 25 years for Daisy
Ridley and John boyega no oh man
to me very cool
making those be flavored enough
[Music]
awesome that's good
why are they together
No
perfect like complementary feature and I
know right it's like they designed it to
be the follow-up secret to the other
feature returned by a marketing team the
first one was all like the nostalgia
encapsulating the you try to push me on
a frame yeah my video now first one was
encapsulating all the nostalgia from all
the films primarily the original far
we've come with these character I mean
like to be fair it is it is kind of a
feat that we've at least for two-thirds
of the trilogy had the same coordinate
force awakens' mainly Han Solo would
some leia and their last jedi mainly
Luke Skywalker with some lamb lamb this
one mainly Leia mainly CGI who's some
Luke apparently bringing it full circle
with Raisa Skywalker is gonna be
fascinating to me I guess it kind of hit
me I know we talked about this when we
covered all the TV spots there's been
parts of me that have been having a
difficult time truly grasping that this
is the end of the Skywalker saga I think
I figured out they talked about it as if
this trilogy finally gets to wrap it up
the Skywalker saga I thought it was
finally wrapped up after the prequels
did it explained it all and we ended it
and then they were like let's bring it
back and continue it so this whole
finally getting to wrap it up thing is
not what I feel no no no you guys are
finally wrapping up this new trilogy you
started that is an addition to it and
you are apparently ending the Skywalker
saga but I think that's where it's fun
where I finally was able to figure out
why I haven't been feeling that because
I've been loving all the nostalgic feels
for it and yeah I completely agree the
feet that it is accomplished over the 40
plus years as many people keep saying
here 40 plus here is truly incredible
and there's a lot to look forward to
like when they talked about Poe Finn and
Reagan and share a lot more screen time
together yeah that's true I don't really
remember much of Rey interacting with
Oscar Isaac in the movie
and so the idea of finally seeing like
the main new face is really sharing the
screen either I can imagine that that
would help bring at least this seven
eight and nine trilogy feel more
complete if they are truly a unit and
then looking back at the other trailers
yeah you do c-3po r2d2 Chewbacca and
then the rest of the new players really
as a whole unit in a lot of the footage
that we've been seeing yeah I'm pretty
excited for this they keep really
emphasizing wrapping it up and tying it
all back and I noticed in that reverse
featurette now it's prequel footage I'm
still curious to see how are they really
going to tie up all nine movies because
I didn't think I never saw that this
movie needed to be that I thought I just
needed to tie up the latest trilogy not
nine movies but they can seem like they
put it this task on tying up nine movies
yeah I mean that's the thing that keeps
plaguing my mind in this whole lead-up
because yeah I do feel like the
emotional side I am like oh wow you know
it's the culmination of another Star
Wars trilogy I guess it's that cynical
side of my mind that sits here and goes
but what does it really mean because I
know there's gonna be more Star Wars and
it seems like you know I mean obviously
they've demonstrated that time is not
that big of a deal in terms of bringing
people back if you want to Daisy Ridley
John boyega Oscar Isaac these people
Austin's we have a lot of time ahead of
them to do a Star War again exactly you
know obi-wan Kenobi's coming back yeah
and advertising is super ephemeral so I
can fathom a world in which five years
from now they're like we're bringing fin
and Rainbow back new chapter and it's
not a Skywalker's yeah yeah yeah I don't
know cuz it cuz also and to be less
cynical I do feel like because this is a
transition because we're saying goodbye
to the original people of the trilogy it
could be cool to see another set of
movies or another movie anyway with the
new characters doing something new in
the Star Wars world you know but I don't
know exactly what that would be I guess
would be called
Rafe and impo a Star Wars story big old
clunky title I feel so much love ends
and the histology feels when I'm
watching these and then when the video
is done
I tend a hard bone this whole wrapping
up nice thing I wonder if when I watch
this movie next week then I'm gonna
agree with that
that's sentiment like if I what if i
rewatch this featurette next week after
watching the movie I'm gonna go oh yeah
I this is what they've been talking
about the whole time I think one of the
saving graces of all is that this is I'm
still pretty excited to see how the
movie turns out because it's been such a
weird road to get here and last Jedi
through so many curveballs into the mix
that I really don't know what this movie
is gonna look like other than the images
with that we've seen but as far as how
it plays out haven't looked at it you've
the leaked information or whatever but
we're leaked information no no I just
assumed there was let's react to it
that's gonna be our most viewed video
then I'm gonna walk out and be like I've
predicted everything here yeah I do like
that I have no idea what to expect from
the Star Wars movie and it's nice
because like Solo I walked in kind of
know and what to expect and I got you
know yeah so I do like that there are so
many ways this could end up and because
all of us are a lot of us are sitting
here going what does wrapping this up
actually mean I'm excited to see what
that always you know in the actual movie
I'm pretty sure Brian is gonna be
crowned king let in you know why not hop
over to this galaxy we can get a
crossover going then we can get a game
of Thrones Star Wars prequel crossover
on HBO max Disney plus cross over event
two networks one streaming service but
you still pay for them both I am so glad
I made that joke alright guys well Star
Wars right Skywalker you get your
tickets you excited these nostalgic
promos are they doing something for you
comment below subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification about to
get notified whenever we got a youtube
video well hit the like button or the
dislike button make sure to check out
host singer comm today
using our promo code the real rejects
saved 91% and I'd like to end this with
a patron of the day shout out to someone
very special a new patron named Cal
durian see pity goose there's a Star
Wars character did you beat me to the
punch line of what I was gonna get -
sorry mister do you know what they call
your super power interrupted in a rut
but to an extreme degree so I've been
talking with this gentleman or woman I'm
not sure
he/she gender-neutral they says from
they from Colorado which I was just
there recently asked where in Colorado
they from Catherine says I'm from the
mountain ute tribe reservation in
Colorado
the town is toy and I asked what his
name means his name currently has no
meaning and I said we'll assign a
meaning to your name during your
shoutouts Oh John you love this talk
dude a call jurian obviously is someone
who is really skilled in the alchemical
arts uses a cauldron to create super
potent potions and as a Star Wars
character that would come in super handy
cuz we don't get much of the chemistry
in the Star Wars universe this is a side
that we could really do with exploring
basically like major name mean which in
so many words matter I think your
ranting abilities hate off great I'm
great at improv when I can just yes and
myself Cal Darian may the force be with
you